well the countdown is on super bowl 55
the big game between the kansas city
chiefs and the tampa bay buccaneers
coming up on
sunday and normally it's a huge economic
boost for the host city but
unfortunately that is not the case with
the pandemic
so people there are getting creative
with ways to cash in
our kevin martin is there live she's
outside the stadium this morning in
tampa
with a new trend giving fans a super
experience hey kevin
good morning
well good morning alex and yes last
year's pre-pandemic super bowl in miami
generated an estimated 572
million dollars in new spending and as
you mentioned
tampa area won't nearly see half of that
but
locals are still trying to cash in on
the extra visitors in town for the big
game and
some are even getting a little creative
and put a new spin
on an old american pastime
this is what tampa is all about right
here football fans from all over
are flocking to sunny tampa to partake
in the festivities of super bowl week
people are definitely looking for things
to do still and they do want safe
alternatives
but with covid protocols and guidelines
in place
fans have had to find new ways to safely
celebrate
like sailgating so definitely a great
alternative to
packing yourself in a bar with a group
of strangers at least
you know you could be just your
immediate family or a tight group of
friends
sailgating is the new tailgating
providing a socially distanced way to
enjoy the beauty of tampa
while also celebrating the big game and
matthew kirkwall is just one of many
boat owners in the bay area
taking advantage of this new trend it's
nice to give people the opportunity to
see the different world from a different
perspective matthew who rents his boat
out year round has been looking forward
to super bowl week for months
for the opportunity to make some extra
cash with the big crowds
you know that is what florida's revenue
comes from
is tourism so definitely have been more
interest
in getting out on the boat this week
while matthew is aiming to have a few
extra
bucks in his pocket as a result of the
super bowl he's also looking at the
bigger picture
and hopes the city as a whole will
benefit from the added tourism
with the hit that it took for covid over
the summertime
we really need some help to bounce back
so you know hopefully this will help
and add insult to injury the weather has
not been ideal the past couple of days
due to the high winds matthew has
actually had to cancel some parties but
he is staying positive
and says he hopes to have football fans
back out on the water
sailgating by wednesday reporting live
in tampa kevin martin 8 sports now
man kevin matthew has the gig on the
water with the dog
that is just ideal life have you seen
anything else there people are doing to
make up the revenue loss
yeah exactly um you know we've all
become familiar with that new term the
new normal well that's kind of
what's going on here in tampa for super
bowl week there's a new normal as far as
the
the festivities that go on for super
bowl week we've seen a lot of the
really popular events for example the
taste of the nfl which was one of the
most
popular events since 1992 is in every
single host city since
that year is all virtual now so fans can
still purchase
tickets online but like i said
everything will be virtual and we've
seen that across the board that
they're still trying to keep the
atmosphere electric and
still have the super bowl weak feel but
also make sure that it's safe and covid
friendly
very cool all right well kevin stay warm
there hope you have a great time
hopefully you find some more dogs to go
on the boats with so
thank you so much we'll see you again
tomorrow morning